hey guys so this is a very quick video
to tell you that there is no video this
week somewhat paradoxically um
basically i have my final exam
theoretical physics in about 30 hours
time uh and i need to revise for that
so i hope you're understanding in me not
uploading a video as normal normal
service actually normal service is never
going to be received because next week
i'll be doing at least a couple of
videos about what i've been up to in
oxford when there hasn't been any work
to do so eight three good night the week
hopefully i'll actually be able to show
you some fun stuff because i realize the
past couple of weeks haven't been fun
for either of us for the one viewer
apparently um but i do want to take this
opportunity uh to say thank you because
i've i've had some really lovely
comments from you guys and some messages
that you've sent me saying thank you for
these videos saying they're motivating
to you that they've made you want to do
well and go to uni and stuff like that
and i really love getting those comments
um it makes my day whenever i get one of
those
and i want you guys to know that
in watching these videos and and leaving
me these comments and sending me
messages you've really motivated me
uh my
motivation levels took a bit of a dip
this year
and
you guys coming to my videos
has really helped me
and i've realized that
it'd be unfair for me to say to you guys
god you've got to do your best in school
that means you get to come here and have
all this fun you know i'm expecting the
best of you you guys should expect the
best of me
i should do my best as well
so you guys have really motivated me to
do that and i can only say thank you
and
actually
if there are any of my friends who are
watching this and any friends
who are watching this in the future i
want to say thank you guys because i
wouldn't have made it this far without
you
uh i really wouldn't especially this
year i've
i really owe you guys several drinks
anyway i i really should go because i'm
a person who's about to theoretical
physics because i'm an oxford and my
math teacher didn't think i should have
taken a level further mass
uh how how am i in this situation again
it's all a bit weird
oh i don't know i'm it's a little bit
weird says the man talking to a camera
in his bedroom uh the morning before one
of the most important exams of his life
makes sense anyway uh i will see you
guys soon sorry for the crappy upload
but this will have to do for this week
the next time you see me i will be a
free man and i will not have my exam
beard actually comment on whether you
like the exam dude i won't keep it but
you know
if you gratify me tonight i can grow a
decent exam be
god this this has been an odd one hasn't
it thanks for sticking around
if you if you are still watching this
part anyway i need to go i will see you
guys next week i will see you on the
other side best of luck to anyone who's
taking exams this week